you got married congratulations thank
you what's tell us how's your life been
changing I mean what's what's um I mean
it hasn't changed that much people says
some people feel they get married and
they think this isn't that different I
mean it feels different it feels more
like a like a bigger responsibility I
think a little bit right um I mean I
think we've been together for three
years now so I think every year you kind
of learn something new about the person
right um and our first year of marriage
I have definitely learned a couple
things about him that I that I didn't
know before like a Lifetime movie
because in those things that she always
meets the perfect guy and it feels like
it's all gonna be just amazing and
perfect and he seems great but then she
finds out he does one weird thing like
he goes in the refrigerator and carves
an apple into little pieces
yeah that's actually a really good
episode but I know that like yeah your
your husband became vegan for you no no
he never do that for me I don't think
but um well I'm a vegan I've been no
vegan for years and oh yeah one there's
literally one guy that's great yeah one
guy everyone else is eating roast beef
sandwiches in the crowd yeah
he he when we first got together he I
was doing this PSA for meatless Mondays
talking about you know you don't have to
be completely vegan but maybe just one
day a week you can not murder an animal
just to be happy no but there were all
these there are all these great reasons
to do that sure and he watched the video
and he thought you know I I can't I
don't think I can sort of go on being
with you and eating the amount of red
meat and meat that I'm eating so I'm
just gonna give up red meat for you and
I thought that was the most romantic guy
I would not do that for anybody I mean
I am Irish Catholic and I have like
fried ham before I go to bed with a
glass of water like that's my version of
aspirin no English English the same
thing same thing when you gave it up for
me for almost two years well a little
over two years and then the second we
got married he would start ordering
things that and he would think that I
what didn't notice that there was like
bacon in his salad and I wouldn't say
anything you know I'm just no I'm not
gonna pressure him but then the other
day we were talking about the most
romantic things we've done for each
other and he said well I think the most
romantic thing I've done for you is give
up red meat and I said no you you you
didn't cuz you just ate it yesterday
yeah and his his face turned white and
he thought like you know he thought he
was getting away with love first of all
is it it's clear to me until he went
right up and sold the wedding and then
he said I do and he took out a Big Mac
on the altar worth I mean he married me
and then he went on to his you know
normal life yeah yeah the life his true
life yes
my wife was didn't eat meat she was
vegetarian yeah and then once she got
pregnant with our daughter it wasn't
even her choice it was like my daughter
inside her and she she had to have meat
because she had been infected by my kind
yeah but did your wife then go back to
being a veget yes once once she had my
daughter that was it and yeah she's just
routinely will be driving you know pass
some cows in the pasture and she jumps
out and starts to treasure
that's not true I just made that out
that's just
you